في الخامس عشر من نوفمبر للعام 2007 كانت
بنغلاديش على موعد مع احد اعنف الاعاصير
التي عرفتها خلال 110 اعوام فخسائر اعصار
صدر الذي تسبب في مقتل نحو ثلاثه الاف
وخمسمائه شخص لم يخلفها اعصار من قبل
فماذا حدث في الرابعه عشر من نوفمبر تم
اصدار اشارات تحذير في ولايتي
الغربيه في بنجلاديش فتم تعليق جميع
الانشطه في ميناء مونجلا ومطار شاه امانات
الدولي مع اتخاذ العديد من الاجراءات
الاحترازيه
في اليوم التالي ضرب الاعصار المناطق
الساحليه مع رياح سرعتها 260 كيلومترا في
الساعه متسببا في حدوث موجات مد وجزر يبلغ
ارتفاعها من 15 الى 20 قدما بعد ذلك
ارتفعت سرعه الرياح في بعض الاحيان لتصل
الى 305 كم في الساعه كانت العاصفه التي
صنفت من الفئه الرابعه مصحوبه بموجات مد
يصل ارتفاعها الى خمسه امتار والى سته
امتار في بعض المناطق
خرقت المياه السدود الساحليه والنهريه
واغرقت المناطق المنخفضه كما تسببت الرياح
العاتيه والفيضانات في الحاق اضرار
بالمساكن والطرق والجسور والبنيه التحتيه
كما تعطلت امدادات الكهرباء والاتصالات
واغلقت الطرق والممرات المائيه
نشرت الحكومه بسرعه مروحيات عسكريه بينما
شق عمال الانقاذ طريقهم الى المناطق
النائيه حيث يعتقد ان قرن باكملها قد سويت
بالارض تم اجلاء نحو مليوني شخص الى ملاجئ
الطوارئ بينما تقطعت السبل بالالاف الذين
لم يجدوا مكانا يذهبون اليه في الجزر
الصغيره
اربع مقاطعات من اصل 30 مقاطعه في
بنغلاديش تاثرت بشده فيما تاثرت ثماني
اخرى بدرجه متوسطه ومن بين مليونين
وثلاثمائه الف اسره تاثرت بالاعصار تضررت
نحو مليون اسره بشكل خطير
تم تدمير اكثر من 450 الف منزل ما دفع
معظم العائلات لبناء شكل من اشكال الماوى
خارج حواجز الاعصار في ظروف قاسيه
قدر عدد الوفيات الناجمه عن الاعصار
بثلاثه الاف واربعمائه وست مع وجود الف
وواحد في عداد المفقودين واكثر من خمسه
وخمسين الف شخص
يعانون من اصابات جسديه
تلوثت مياه الشرب بالحطام وغمرت العديد من
المصادر بالمياه المالحه من موجات المد
والجزر كذلك تضرر القطاع الزراعي بسبب
الفيضانات التي غطت نحو مليون هكتار من
الاراضي الخصبه
قدرت الاضرار والخسائر بنحو مليار
وسبعمائه مليون دولار امريكي
كان اعصار سدر ثانيه كارثه طبيعيه تضرب
بنجلاديش خلال 12 شهرا في دوله تقع
بالكامل تقريبا على دلتا ضخمه تشكلت من
التقاء مجموعه انهار تتغذى باستمرار من
ذوبان ثلوج جبال الهيمالايا حيث تعد
الكوارث الطبيعيه ضيفه مقيمه وليست زائره
عابره